en forêt amazonienne des compagnies
pharmaceutiques peu scrupuleuses tentent
de s'approprier certaines plantes pour
fabriquer de nouveaux médicaments
le souci c'est que ces firmes spolie
allègrement les populations locales pour
tenter de médiatiser ce problème un
chaman originaire d'équateur a fait le
déplacement jusqu'en france jusqu à
cavaillon où se déroule le festival
science frontières jeunes barré et
gérard gayaud le rencontrer reportage
c'est la première fois que ce chaman
quitte son pays l'équateur
à peine descendu de l'avion il découvre
les rues de cavaillon dans le vaucluse
il se dit étonné par nos technologies
nos voitures me présente le magasin et
ne passage piéton bien étrange mais ce
sont nos plantes même en ville qui
attire le plus l'attention c'est
certainement une utilisation curatives
on doit déjà l'utiliser ailleurs il
faudrait vivre avec elle pour apprendre
d'elle ce chaman est invité au 17e
festival science frontières c'est pour
pousser un cri d'alarmé
actuellement des compagnies
pharmaceutiques tentent de breveter des
plantes médicinales qui font partie de
la pharmacopée traditionnelle pour en
avoir un usage exclusif ignorant les
populations locales
les indiens d'amazonie devrait ainsi
payer pour utiliser leurs plantes
il existe déjà des cas de bio piraterie
on va perdre dans un premier temps notre
identité culturelle
ensuite on va nous interdire d'utiliser
nos plans ceci est notre culture et on
veut défendre nos portes médicinales
c'est une forme de vol direct depuis
1981 date d'un arrêt de la cour suprême
américaine le droit international
reconnaît que tout est brevetable
animaux végétaux micro-organismes mêmes
j'anime seul le sommet de rio en 92 a
tenté de construire un rempart
législatif pour protéger le vivant et
que si un industriel tire une invention
de retard d'une ressource biologique du
pays ou y
il veut renverser des redevances à la
population locale
ceci est la théorie car dans la pratique
les états sont bien petit face à la
puissance des compagnies pharmaceutiques
et ne sont pas toujours à l'écouté des
indiens qui ne représentent parfois que
10 % de leur population
les chamans ne veulent pas être
dépossédés de leurs connaissances
médicinales et des plantes qui sont leur
héritage et leur avenir